The Model-based Embedded and
Robotic Systems Group at MIT
is collaborating with the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
at Caltech on a project
that will enable astronauts
to safely work with robots
in an easy and intuitive way.
One example of such
a robot is ATHLETE,
a vehicle developed
at JPL that will
support robotic
and human missions
on the surface of the Moon.
ATHLETE is capable
of rolling or walking
over extremely rough
or steep terrain,
and can load, transport,
manipulate, and deposit
payloads to any desired
sites of interest.
Previously, robots
have been simple enough
to be controlled
through teleoperation
or direct commanding.
However, more complex robots,
like ATHLETE or the Vecna BEAR
battlefield robot,
have too many degrees
of freedom for direct
teleoperation or commanding
to be practical.
We've developed a
different control paradigm
that incorporates
verbal commands, shared
written instructions,
and demonstration
by example to enable more
efficient interaction.
These modes of communication
occur naturally to humans
during collaborative tasks.
Here is an example of a
common-sense written plan where
the human and
athlete work together
to collect rock
samples for analysis.
The instructions
include descriptions
of both the human's tasks
and ATHLETE's tasks.
A key challenge
to executing tasks
is grounding terms like pick
up into ATHLETE motions.
We reduce time and
effort required
to do this by teaching
actions through demonstration.
We use an interface
device called
TRACK developed by the
Distributed Robotics Lab at MIT
to teleoperate the robot
through each desired activity
several times.
Here we're teaching
athlete retirement pick up
by showing athlete how to pick
up an object without hitting
the box.
Based on the
demonstrated motions,
are learning algorithm
generalizes from the examples
a set of motions
that will likely
achieve the action of pick up.
This is compactly encoded
in the representation we
call a probabilistic flow tube.
Once ATHLETE learns
the activity,
it can autonomously execute
the corresponding nominal
trajectory.
The learned flow tube
represents flexibility
in the motions the robot
can choose to perform,
enabling it, for example, to
recover from disturbances.
The width of the flow
tube indicates areas
with more or less flexibility.
After ATHLETE knows how to
perform each of its tasks
individually, it can
collaborate with the human
to execute the
written plan together.
We have developed
an executive that
allows ATHLETE to make
decisions at runtime
to improve the likelihood
of successfully completing
the plan.
Specifically, ATHLETE schedules
the start times and durations
of each activity
with flexibility,
while ensuring that limbs
synchronize successfully.
This allows it to react
appropriately to the human
and still perform the
actions correctly.
We demonstrated our
capabilities by integrating them
with the ATHLETE prototype at
JPL, and by showing a human
and ATHLETE cooperating
to complete this task.
First, the human attaches a
gripper to ATHLETE's left limb.
The executive timestamps
this activity duration
when the person is done so
it can accommodate changes
in the human's activities.
Now ATHLETE is moving
the gripper near the rock
in preparation to pick it up.
This complex motion was learned
using the techniques described
earlier.
Since ATHLETE can't sense the
precise location of the rock,
the person can assist ATHLETE
by fine-tuning the gripper
location through
voice commanding.
Move limb six forward
5 centimeters.
Next, the human attaches have
been to ATHLETE's right limb.
The gripper closes on
the rock to pick it up.
At this point, both
limbs move in position
to drop the rock into the box.
Finally, ATHLETE stores the
box for transport, which
is the end goal of the plan.
In the future, we plan to
demonstrate its capabilities
with more complex
plans that involve
the humans safely coordinating
with multiple robots.
Engineers at JPL are currently
developing the next generation
of ATHLETE robots
called Tri-ATHLETE,
in which each robot
has three limbs
and can coordinate together to
transport habitats and perform
more complex manipulation tasks.
In the future, we aim to
show humans working safely
in the same environment
as the Tri-ATHLETEs
in order to support future
operation on the Moon.
Funding for this
task was provided
through the JPL Strategic
University Research Partnership
Program and the National
Defense Science and Engineering
Graduate Fellowship.